so the new
top gun movie came out top gun maverick
and i mean we just couldn't really help
but
to talk to
the real top gun
dave burke is here
what's happening dave what's up jocko
good to be here man dave burke if you
don't know him uh marine corps fighter
pilot
top gun
fighter pilot top gun instructor top gun
senior instructor
commander the first operational f-35
squadron
on the ground with
my task unit
in the battle of ramadi as an anglico
guy
leading an anglico team
air naval gunfire liaison
so
that's how we got to know each other
initially now we work together
you can fly an f-18
an f-16 an f-22
and an f-35
how many people in the world can do that
i know it sounds crazy but i actually
don't know of anybody else that was
qualified in all four it may have
happened in the last couple years i
don't know about it but well who would
get the call now
the the real kicker is is
the f-22 yeah
that doesn't fit with both the f-18 and
the f-16 it fits with one or the other
but actually it doesn't really fit with
anything anymore but so i think the
chances of that happening are pretty
slim it's kind of cool so you are
it's safe to say you're you're you could
be considered a little bit of an expert
on
this kind of thing
yeah i guess
so all right top gun before we jump into
it yeah what what
what is top gun explain it real quick so
top gun like the real top gun is just a
nickname for what's called the the
united states navy fighter weapon school
it's just a school that has been around
for a while since since 1969 it's just a
school that teaches kind of a graduate
level capability for fighter pilots to
be ready for war we can certainly go in
a lot more detail
the the school is called the navy
fighter weapons school it got the
nickname top gun because very early on
it was literally about
gunnery like it had its origins and
being able to use the airplane correctly
and use the gun on the plane well
and i'm really paraphrasing but it comes
from that so the name top gun has stuck
from the beginning and it got a lot of
prominence from the first movie top gun
is where that name really kind of rung
through but top gun by itself is really
just a nickname for the school
so
you take normal pilots from the navy and
the marine corps does anyone from the
air force go there no we used to have an
exchange program once in a blue moon but
no i would say it's it's almost
exclusively now mostly maybe a couple of
marines so navy marine corps and you go
there and you learn to dog fight
amongst other things yes but that is the
foundational thing you start to teach
and learn up there and you scrap in the
sky you you go up and you dog fight
other
really good pilots yes
and so
if
who gets selected to go there do you
have to be the best guy in your in your
squadron
yeah you have to be in the top tier of
your squadron there's some things you
have to work out some timing you know
some other things beyond your control
and
you don't get ranked there's not like a
board that says dave burke is number one
and somebody else is number two but
there's definitely a tier that you need
to be in and there's some certifications
where the the squadron kind of can judge
you along the way and you need to be at
the at the top uh towards the top of
your peer group to be selected so you
got selected to be to go to top gun
school yeah then you what go on a couple
deployments then you get how do you get
selected to be a top gun instructor did
you have to kind of do well at the top
yeah so what's unique about that and
it's it's a very unique for marines
which i really like because the marine
corps has a unique selection program
the way it works for the marine corps
you got to get selected to go from your
squadron so your squadron just gets a
billet and so the average math is
every squadron's gonna send one person a
year it might be two one year none the
next because you're deployed but it sort
of works out to one a year is the basic
math how many how many pilots in the
squadron 17 kind of regular pilots and
then like co exo so you know just around
20 or so check
in that selection process you got it you
get picked to go by your commander your
commanding officer gets to pick and you
know there's a probably process he uses
and then as the marine they send you up
to top gun and you'll do the full
13-week top gun course and you go right
back to your squadron which is a little
bit different the navy you'll you'll
either stay to teach at a schoolhouse
whereas the marine corps you go right
back to your squadron and most commonly
you'll go back to your squadron and
you'll deploy
and then
at some point in there
the marines and the rest of the staff
will vote and select on which marines
they want to bring back there's only
three pilots on the staff of 25 that are
marines
so
to come back as a marine humblebrag
it's kind of crazy math and by looking
back on it to come back as a marine is
it's a pretty narrow window you got to
thread the needle to be
available
eligible and meet the staff's
expectations of what they're looking for
to bring you back to bring you back as
an instructor and then how hard is it to
be the senior instructor there is that
based on what's that based on is it
based on your seniority or what's it
based on
it's a combination of things i mean you
have to be a more senior pilot you know
the most junior guys are not going to be
and the senior pilot is called the
training officer that's the pilot on the
staff at 25 that's really picked to run
the class
and so that's where you were i was as a
marine i was a training officer which
was at the time like the best job
because you're basically running top gun
as a um is a relatively junior person in
the military how often do they pick a
marine to do that
not that often there's a handful i mean
i'm not the only one for sure but
it's not that common it's pretty
uncommon for a marine to get a chance to
be the training officer top gun how do
you know
so it's not based on seniority so is it
just you're kind of the best pilot is
that sort of what's happening
there is a combination of factors at
play
what they really want
is someone
who is a good pilot who's experienced
who is senior
um but they want someone who's got two
unique capabilities together you have to
be a really good teacher
so of course your teaching skill is
really critical but you also have to be
able to be able to lead a peer group who
even though you might be a senior you're
going to be like just a few months
here's not some big difference in
seniority so it's really
do you trust someone to be able to lead
a peer group of
pretty evenly matched even capability
even experienced pilots and be able to
lead them as
really peers so combination of how good
of a teacher you are and how well do you
think you can lead your peers which is
not easy to do so it's a combination of
things does it help if you shoot all
them down it does help if you're
credibility goes a long way in in
anything but certainly
fighter aviation if you're good in the
jet that's going to help you for sure
all right so
that's kind of what top gun is yeah and
that's where you were
uh
the first top gun movie what year did it
come out 86 and you said you saw it in
86 i did and that
impacted the trajectory of your life 100
i was 13. so if you can kind of picture
the brain of a 13 year old i was ripe
for that kind of influence and that's
100 why you chose the path you chose i
had already
even younger than that had had
i wouldn't say just explored i had
already decided i want to be in the
military i think you know when you're 12
or 13 it's it's a little
not clear as to even what or why but i
knew i was already inclined i thought
airplanes were cool i thought the
military was cool i was already moving
in that direction
when i saw that on the movie it really
narrowed this i think i want to be in
the military too i want to fly jets
around boats like it got really narrow
from that
how did you end up in the marine corps
instead of the navy that's a good
question because when i saw that movie
of course immediately you go towards the
navy because
naval aviation is mostly around the navy
and the airplane was a navy jet they
have 14 tomcat it's all about the navy
so there's not really a connection to
the marine corps what was unique for me
is i grew up right around the corner
like a mile away from a marine base
so inside of that there's a little piece
of really thinking the marine corps was
cool as a little kid kind of being
enamored with marines
and having this little
sense of something about the marine
corps to me was unique and anybody that
that really migrates towards the marine
corps there's an intangible quality
about the marine corps it's really
undeniable and i already had that so i
saw this movie i'm like man i want to do
that and at some point relatively soon i
don't know if i was at an air show or
somebody explained it somebody made the
connection that marines
fly jets off ships and when i was like
holy cow
i can do both of those things
and i combine them marine flying jets
off ships that's when it was like i'm
going to do exactly that thing
yeah you were just hook line and sinking
all day all in all right so what did you
do for okay so for the new movie
top gun maverick what did you have to do
with it you did something for it i did
it was kind of cool so
you know this movie just came out
memorial day 2022 the movie's been done
for a couple of years it got delayed you
know for code and whatnot so this is
probably back in 16 or 17 when they
really started to
come to grips that they're going to make
a sequel they knew what was going to go
on
and they had a couple of screenwriters
they had a a guy one of the guys who
wrote the script for the movie
we had a common friend and i don't even
remember what the connection was but i
got linked up with him what year was
this
16 maybe okay 16. yeah i think 16 is
probably right so kind of early on in
the development and he had written an
initial script
and
he i think on behalf of the navy on
behalf of tom cruise on behalf of a
bunch of people they really wanted it to
be authentic so he actually came out and
spent a couple days with me
and we went through that thing and what
he was looking for was
is this how it would be is this what
they would do is this how they would say
it so i got a chance to go through kind
of beginning to end and help contribute
and listen my contributions were small
but i got to contribute to
the authenticity of how you'd go about
doing it and if you haven't flown it it
might be hard to understand some of the
nuance and they really wanted to get the
nuance right so i got to help with that
which was really cool
is there anything was there any scene
was there any words was there any lines
where you're like that's that's right
there that's me
any movements
i don't think i made the connection to
me individually but there were things
that they there's a key theme that i
really liked that comes out and i'm
going to assume that most people now for
seeing the movies i'm not going to give
anything away but there's a theme about
as technology moves on as technology
gets better a lot of people buy into the
idea that oh better technology wins now
you and i both know that is not true now
technology helps technology is awesome
but in the end especially in when you're
fighting one against one or force
against force it comes down to the
person flying the machine and that's the
cool thing about aviation is it's
airplanes are really good equalizers
they wanted to keep with the theme that
they you know the person in the box the
man in the box
and so they they understood and i helped
get to the idea that it's not that the
airplane is better than ours or vice
versa it's the person flying it and that
was a theme that we talked about and it
really made its way into the movie which
is cool
humblebrag coming at you again hey it's
not about the machine it's about me dave
burke best pilot ever
i'm so glad i'm here right now
uh what was your overall so now you've
seen the completed movie i saw it too
totally i saw it so we could do this
because i didn't want to be completely
blind and it was very fortuitous in the
fact that my wife
i made it into a date i was like oh you
know i'd really like to see this and she
was like she was all happy because you
know i'm like the worst
person for doing fun things or whatever
she was all excited so we went she was
ea
as we went let's go see it
so we've seen the movie i've seen the
movie what was your overall impression
how did they do dude i thought it was
awesome i loved it now i also knew i was
going to see a movie so in terms of like
what i was thinking and my criteria for
it um for the baseline i was expecting
dude i thought it was awesome
it's a hollywood movie and we have to
take our knowledge
and kind of suspend it a little bit for
these type of situations
i think that's a movie like this i think
that's the best word you got to suspend
some of those things i was not there
looking at how they laid out the tactics
and the format i looked at it as this is
a movie but it's also a movie that's
connected to a world that i know really
really well
and there's elements that i wanted to
see how how well they could depict that
not about the tactics of the moves in
the airplane but what it's like to be in
an airplane and
there's also some cool themes in there
too
that i really liked
like america is awesome when we build
really cool stuff and we can go anywhere
and do anything so there's a lot of
things about the movie that i really
liked and overall for what i was
expecting
i love that movie
yeah i thought it was good too and
another thing you have to take is when
you're watching these movies whether
it's a war movie or this guy i guess
this is allegedly a war movie or kind of
a war movie
you have to take that they've got to get
all these
different complicated things into an
hour and a half two hours
personalities emotion like they gotta do
it so they gotta make some they gotta
make some adjustments in reality to make
it to make it hit the way it's supposed
to all right so
uh the pilots in the movie
the various pilots in the movie how did
they how are those personalities did
they did they nail it
yeah it's funny because you know
had this movie come out 10 years ago
i probably would even look at it
differently than i do now because half
of the way i'm looking at this now is
through the lens of leadership and
personalities and the stuff that we talk
about at echelon front all the time
um so like i said kind of going back in
one sense i saw the first when i was 13
or 14. and so part of me is looking at
this movie thinking what does 13 or 14
year old dave burke think of this movie
and
part of the reason why i'm so positive
about this movie is i think any 13 14
year old influential kid watching this
what i said the other day was
millions of kids are going to want to
join the navy and fly airplanes which to
me is a huge win that's awesome
in the leadership lens i'm looking at
ego i'm looking at all these other
nuanced things and they do magnif they
magnify the personalities to do exactly
what you described they got two hours to
depict all these things so they take
these individual personalities and they
magnify them so they're really obvious
to see
and so in some sense i didn't have a lot
of experience with people whose
personalities were that kind of i guess
over the top in some ways but i could
identify and and resonate with every
single one so i think in that sense they
still did a good job depicting
ego complacency
a bunch of other subtle attributes you
really got to think about in order for
someone to be successful in difficult
situations so i thought they did a good
job of that too
and then how about the mission profile
uh
first of all what was the reason why
they needed to use an f-18 instead of an
f-35 or some other mechanism like a
t-lam or something like that what they
made a comment um that i think to allow
them to use the f-18 which was hey this
is the ideal mission for the f-35 but
the gps jamming negates the weapons
so if people have asked me like did you
think that was a slight on the f35 or
unrealistic and i'm like no they just
wanted to use the f-18 so they had a
reason to use the f-18 and the reason
they gave was the f-35 gps weapons
wouldn't work in a gps jammed
environment whether that's true or not
kind of but it certainly was plausible
enough to explain why they're doing it
the way they did it so that actually
made sense it's fine uh
that said
there's pilots out there can have all
sorts of opinions on it
but if you again look at it through the
lens of this is a movie it was totally
fine why did they want to use the f-18s
oh because that's why you want to bring
tom cruise back maverick back
i think his number one criteria and i
think one of the things the navy wanted
to do is they wanted it to be as
realistic as possible
and despite how good cgi is and computer
stuff is really cool
you cannot replicate a lot of what you
saw in the movie their faces g-forces
all that stuff
and if you want to put two people on an
airplane you need to fly an f-18 because
there's no two-seat f-35s and you're not
gonna film a movie with the singles at
35 and make it look real at least not
this real so they needed hornets which
is totally fine dang
so that's legit yes they
okay the physical aspect of being a
fighter pilot
wha what's the reality there you know
you got tom cruise you got these people
making it look like it's all hard how
hard is it come on the reality is i'm
sitting across from jocko willing navy
seal and
the reality is it's not like this all
the time but flying fighters is
exhausting sometimes like
very physically demanding
and
um there are components of flying that
physiologically are really really hard
and i think they wanted to depict those
segments now it's not usually quite as
sustained as difficult it is there's
elements of flight that are like
downright boring like navigating to and
from you're just sitting there you're
just sitting in a cockpit and then
there's times that there's extreme
levels of physiological challenges
that a lot of human beings would
struggle with and i think they wanted to
depict that there are times that flying
is
mind-blowingly difficult both spatially
like thinking about three dimensions and
physically when you have eight or nine
g's on the airplane and if you're close
to 200 pounds with your gear you're
feeling 1800 pounds something like that
and you're literally feeling that having
to look around and do things those can
be really hard
you don't do that for hours at a time
you do it for minutes at a time but
inside those few minutes that can be
tough and i've always enjoyed taking
people out and they come back and when
they land they they don't know that
they're going to be as tired as they are
so there's some adapting physiologically
that is pretty hard do you have to do
did you guys have certain workouts that
you did totally absolutely i mean
standard thing you got to have like
strong glutes strong hamstrings and you
have to have really good technique for
breathing and if you have the right
muscles and the right technique really
anybody of any build can physiologically
adapt to high g flying
how many hours when you were a top gun
instructor how many hours would you fly
a day that was physically challenging so
like how many hours are you dog fighting
a day like in a good day like a good day
at top gun i'd get two maybe three dog
fights like three would be a really good
day so we'll just say let's say it's two
a dog a one against one dog fight flight
would be 45 minutes total and of that
you're probably
25
ish minutes per flight like under g like
really maneuvering and bending the jet
around so that's what a bfm flight would
be about 25 minutes of that
i flew in an f18
i did the backseat ride up at fallon
nevada which is where top gun ended up
this was before top gun was there yeah
pretty sure and pulled i think seven and
a half g's
and flew around and did a
bomb drop and did a dog fight so i had
like a cool experience for for that the
the
mission in the movie
they have to fly up over this thing and
that's a normal procedure
because i've done it it's and i remember
this in the pop that's a thing right
exactly so talk us through that yeah so
you're flying at low level to avoid
radar which is real
yeah
that whole mission at the end
every segment of that mission is things
that i routinely and what pilots do
routinely in f-18s on a regular basis
and not like top gun pilots just any
pilot as a routine series of
pieces of emission that you would do to
include what you described the low level
ingress the high g pop
the really high climb acceleration the
rolling on your back high g turn why do
you have to roll on your back
so
to go from pointed high to pointed low
meaning nose up to nose down because
they're diving down towards the target
if you push on the jet going as fast as
they are it's probably five six hundred
miles an hour the number of negative g's
you would
we wouldn't black out it's called red
out like you would put so much blood in
your brain that you would you couldn't
you physiologically couldn't do it so
you roll onto your back so when you pull
the apply the g it's in the right
direction it's the type of g that you
want and so instead of getting all
weightless and floating and just making
it really slow and painful you roll
inverted and you pull really hard
because it's the type of g's you're
designed for so you roll inverted and
you pull down to get into the dive in a
way that you can tolerate when i did
that
the one time i did it it was awesome how
fast that the aircraft goes you're
you're flying right side up also you're
upside down yes it's like instantaneous
it is fast yeah and then you're
then you can see that i thought it was
so you could see the target better there
is a component of that so a move like
that like coming over a ridge line it's
to be able to get the jet pointed down
towards the target as fast as you can um
the the technique of doing that you
could debate all day but the maneuver is
a real maneuver that we do routinely
what about
the afterburner
talk to me about that yeah
um so you have a drink called
afterburner right i do afterward orange
yes
well why'd you call the drink
afterburner orange and what does
afterburner do to a plane what does
afterburner orange do to your brain yeah
you know they both serve very similar
functions which is kind of cool i think
the name for me was pretty obvious i
think in the first like seven seconds of
the original movie top gun
uh there's like a jet on a the tomcat is
on the catapult and goes in a full
afterburner and it's this giant huge
orange flame which is giving this jet a
bunch of additional thrust and most
catapult launches you take in what's
called full afterburner uh and then
really the technique behind afterburner
in general is
you're flying around in a regular engine
it just spins and puts out thrust after
burner is where they take literally
liquid fuel and they spray it in the
back so it kind of creates like a mini
explosion and just shoots a red an
orange flame out the back but it gives
the jet a whole bunch of additional
thrust so what it gives you in in
somewhat limited time frames a bunch of
extra speed or a bunch of extra ability
to maneuver what percentage of extra
power am i getting
is it like double power is it like 20
percent more so here's an example like
um when you're in full power without
afterburner they call it mill and those
engines that you saw and i'll get close
i'll kind of use the original hornet you
get about just under 11 000 pounds of
thrust in a mill rated engine
if you go to afterburner you get about
18 000 pounds of thrust so it's not
quite double but it's a big jump and if
you go from two engines so twenty two
thousand pounds
to thirty six thousand pounds you're
getting a big additional boost in thrust
a lot you can feel it you you absolutely
go back in yourself yes you accelerate
quick
and then uh you made a drink that's
called that
same thing it's exact same thing there
are times my normal steady state i'm
pretty good to go for the day i get up
i'm good till the evening but there are
times i need that little that little
kicker
and that drink for obvious reasons the
name but you also get that little hitter
that'll give you what you need to to get
through some more challenging times if
you need that little enhancement
how about
staying cool as a pilot i i talk about
this a lot you know from a seal
perspective you know you always want to
say sound calm on the radio to make
everyone else calm and make yourself not
sound like you're freaking out or losing
your mind
how much detachment do you have to have
as a pilot to remain calm in pressure
situations
a lot i mean the concept of detachment
is something that's kind of universal we
talk it about it in leadership it's no
no different than an airplane
the way you communicate
and the way you sound is is i think two
things one it's a reflection of how
detached you are and you want to be
detached because you want to see as many
things as you can especially in a jet
you want to look around and see a lot of
things you don't want to be looking at
just one thing
but you also want to give the impression
that despite the amount of chaos that's
going around
you want the people that you're talking
to to think that you're calm
and if they think that you're calm like
hey this isn't that bad this isn't that
stressful we're going to be okay they
tend to react the same way now there are
times that on a radio and it's not all
that common but there are times i want
to convey a little extra emotion to get
you to move quicker and i might elevate
my voice or or speak in a kind of a
higher octave or or a little faster or
louder those are typically calculated
times when i really need a reaction
and i don't think it's much different
than the way you describe being a seal
and it's really no different than any
leadership role is the times that i do
that i'm pretty
judicious about doing that and it's
because i want to get a reaction the
rest of the time i want to sound cool
calm collected and just like hey this
situation this situation is no factor
we're good
um i got some general notes from the
movie
uh
one thing that was interesting was there
was one part where
a pilot screwed something up and he's
like this is my fault
is that standard taking ownership or did
you put that in there
at top gun it's pretty standard by the
time you get there
you have figured out early on your
career that the standard litany of
excuses that you're gonna make
first of all they haven't been tolerated
by anybody else nobody wants to hear
your excuses and after a while you come
to realize that anything that didn't go
well is actually your fault
it's
doubly true if you spent your life by
yourself in an airplane i mean who else
are you going to blame for anything
that's gone wrong so
the best pilots early on come to grips
that any problem that's been created out
there is your fault and you know a
little humility and why not but yeah
despite what you might see
the humility that most aviators have to
be successful is recognizing it if
something went wrong at your fault
there's a scene where or there's
actually a couple scenes where this
happens where maverick is going against
the the other top gun pilots he's just
slaughtering like time after time after
time and i know you and i have talked
about this
that's pretty realistic i was thinking
to myself if i was watching this i think
oh if i didn't know anything i'd be like
oh that's unrealistic that he would just
go kill everyone but he actually would
yeah if you're that much better of a
pilot
now
he's a top gun instructor and these guys
are just regular top gun pilots so it
still is realistic that he would just
slaughter them all yeah not really
competitive i don't think anybody inside
of top gun as a student or an instructor
would say that the most proficient
instructor
is significantly better than the most
proficient student like a big big big
difference okay so the best instructor
is way better
than the best student yes and so that
was an accurate depiction he's just up
there murking people yeah i mean the
students come through even students that
are graduates they're good i mean these
are good pilots this is not that they're
not good in the airplane
but instructors are getting so many reps
they got so much experience they've seen
it so many times that the difference
between
sort of the senior
bfm or dog fighting pilot at top gun
versus
you know even a top gun graduate there's
a huge disparity there
how about g-lock
talk me through g-lock what happens
that's a thing absolutely um
fortunately in the f-18 it's not quite
as prominent as it is in some other
airplanes i think the most notorious
g-lock plane out there that's flying is
the f-16 which is just the coolest jet
um it's an unbelievable machine and it
is a very very high g platform it pulls
just over nine g's
the problem with the f-16 is you can go
from one to nine g's and i think it's
like a second or something really really
fast yeah
so if your technique isn't perfect and
if your physiological conditioning and
current situation that day isn't perfect
in that second you can black out really
fast so this idea of g-lok which stands
for g induced loss of consciousness is a
real thing and so what they teach pilot
teach pilots to do is before the onset
of that g meaning pulling back on the
stick
you pre uh you start ahead of time by
controlling your breathing tensing the
right muscles and anticipating the pull
the problem is sometimes when you have
to react you look over your shoulder and
you see you're you're being shot at and
sometimes you'll onset those g's before
you set it up correctly and that's when
g-lock tends to happen but it is a real
thing we have
we have crashed planes we have killed
pilots and we have actually introduced
technology design specifically
for that because it is a it's such a
common prominent thing
where you're killing a pilot and an
airplane that are otherwise perfectly
functioning correctly and we don't want
that
bird strike that's a thing that is a
thing that's a thing and you have
procedures that you're going to roll
through 100
it's not common for a bird strike to
snuff out a motor like that but it is
that it has absolutely happened it's
very uncommon bird strikes are not that
uncommon for a bird strike to get you to
crash the airplane
very rare but
not unheard of and
she's going through who's a female pilot
though so there's procedures you're just
going to follow these procedures yeah
and they were actually pretty close on
that too they weren't super far off the
mark there's a couple things that a
pilot go oh that's not right that's not
right but generically speaking
they had it right and that's what you
have to do you can't freak out oh my
gosh you just gotta oh here's the
procedures cut this engine restart this
thing turn off this fuel thing boom you
just go through the procedures are those
memorized they call it immediate action
i bet you i i still know the engine fire
immediate action i could probably do it
right now
i'm gonna do it
[Music]
uh
what is the life of a pilot
like just day to day
like at work yeah
mostly not flying
so
you know i talked about it earlier is if
you go up and fly let's say once a day
which
is more
than you normally would in a regular
squadron um
prepping for a flight takes a lot of
time but the day-to-day life of a pilot
especially in the marine corps and it's
also very true in the navy is
you have a job
you're in charge of a department or a
division or potentially in charge of the
whole squadron so a lot of your time is
dedicated towards the department you're
responsible for and the individual
marines or sailors that work for you and
what that department has to deliver so
at a bare minimum you know you're kind
of 50 50 splitting between your role as
a pilot and your role as a leader in the
squadron
uh
so i watched the movie and at one point
and spoiler alert whatever sorry tom
cruise gets shot down
now in my mind this is the point where
the movie was going to get really good
because they were going to send a seal
team in to get him out of there i mean
this was i said okay cool this is going
to get this right
they're going to get this right they're
going to make it work
and i was kind of bummed out when that
didn't happen until they stole an f-14
right and brought the tomcat back and
then i said uh you know what we'll go
with it i still thought we might see
some seals maybe do some recovery at
some point they kind of blew that
look they're not gonna they're not gonna
be able to nail everything perfectly and
plus you don't want you know a movie
that's supposed to be about jet fighters
you don't want the whole movie to get
stolen by you know seven minutes of a
seal platoon going in there and kicking
ass and taking names which you know
probably could have happened so
i think they did it right uh just just
to maintain the integrity of the movie
and keep the focus on on the on the
pilots which is fine
uh how about the next generation of
fighter pilots you talked about the fact
that
it's not the plane it's the pilot but
what about
i thought there's another thing i
thought
as soon as the movie started i thought
okay this is going to be
human versus
computer human versus ai human versus
drone that's what i thought it was going
i was surprised that they even put
pilots in the other aircraft
how many generations are we away from
having no more fighter pilots
yeah
i got asked a somewhat similar question
after the premiere and i i think i
discovered i might be
i don't know about alone no i don't know
if i'm wrong i mean obviously the future
will be what it is
but my opinion i think maybe is not as
universally shared as i thought so we
just really in the last you know
decade or so introduce what we call
fifth-gen airplanes that's the f-22
raptor and the f-35 lightning
of course
the fact that i flew them and flew them
both was crazy super lucky to get to see
that and i got exposure to that whole
new generation of pilots where there's
still of airplanes there's still pilots
that's never flown either of those
so we just really are the beginning of
fifth generation and i would say that
those planes the raptor and the
lightning you're gonna have those things
around for like 20 30 years a long time
and we are now getting to the part where
we're building
our sixth gen or building is a strong
word designing and starting to think
about what that airplane will be so i
don't know in the next 10 or some odd
years the next generation is to start
being more of a reality that's going to
go another that'll take 30 years
are they putting a pilot in sixth
generation they are the the next
generation plane which is certainly
being designed is going to be a manned
fighter
my conclusion is that
i won't be in the least bit surprised if
that's the last man fighter we ever
built and i'm just looking like that's
30 40 potentially 50 years of these two
fifth and sixth generation platforms you
know flying
that if we don't do another one after
that it won't surprise me now
i've come to realize that a lot of
pilots don't agree with it uh
what do a lot of pilots think i think
there is a belief and that might be true
for some mission sets there's a belief
that you have to have someone in the
cockpit oh okay i thought it was going
to be the other direction
that i'm that
that you were the one person that
thought oh we still need people for
another 50 years
i don't think so i i and again i'm
not 100 sure on this but i think most
pilots would tell you
um
at a minute well at a minimum the next
generation is going to be a man fighter
i think that's kind of a universally
known thing and that there are some
people i think believe that you will
always have to have someone in the
airplane
i think that
if in my lifetime we build an unmanned
fighter i won't be surprised at all
but from your perspective
the 13 year old 14 year old that just
saw this movie he's going to be good to
go she's going to be good to go if they
want to get into an aircraft and fly
that thing as a fighter pilot they're
going to have that option no problem
what's crazy is that if you're in that
same age i was if you're 14 years old
and you're watching that movie and you
actually get on the path to do that
you'll be flying jets in 10 years like
you'll be in you'll be 10 years from now
you'll be flying a fighter so
i qualified in the hornet i was 24. and
if i think about you know from 14 to 24
it's a short amount of time to have that
much development from a kid watching a
movie to being in the cockpit of a
fighter so
if you're watching that as a teenager
now and you're thinking i might want to
do this no factor you're going to get a
chance to do it
that's what i'm talking about alright
any closing thoughts on the movie
i liked that movie a lot i was it was
better than i thought for a lot of
different reasons and you know again
there's people out there discussing
the things that are wrong yes it is a
movie unquestionably but from what i was
looking for my experience i was stoked
to see that movie when's the last time
you watched the og oh dang
does it hold
the the og in my house is is a little
bit of a thing like with my kids and
stuff
um and certainly with my circle of
friends so
i've seen bits and p to see beginning
then i cannot remember the last time i
sat down and watched the movie
the last time i saw parts or pieces or
clips from youtube it happens like on
the regular so i know that movie will
and it holds its it holds up today i
think so what's crazy about that movie
is how many people
in the last 35 years have seen that and
think the movie is awesome there aren't
a lot of movies from the 80s that that
can keep up just for just basic you know
cultural
like you just look at things like that
looks old because there's real airplanes
and because there's real flying i think
it holds up pretty well did you get
issued aviator glasses you totally
did you wear them
at all
times uh second lieutenant and first
lieutenant dave burke wore them at all
times at some point
um and i think people might know this
from my social media post
between that and my flat top
i outgrew them both but it took a while
when did you transfer from to an a
regular pair of sunglasses from aviators
do you ever break out the aviators at
this point
i i broke them out the other day to go
see topics go see the premiere my wife
actually wore my
uh my flight jacket oh yeah so there's a
picture out there floating around her in
my you know dave burke standard issue
fighter pilot jacket is this is that a
leather jacket it is
that's issued it is you have you got
patches on it i do
what's your most sacred patch on that
jacket
uh the most sacred patch on that is my
first fighter squadron which sits on
like your chest so
um
it's sort of i don't know how it is in
the teams but you will always hold a
special place for your first squadron
and you'll kind of always go back to
that first tour that first deployment
that first experience in that first
squadron and no matter what else you do
you're gonna that's gonna
that's gonna stay close
so that's what's on there
awesome all right well with that
if you haven't seen the movie
suspend
disbelief a little bit check it out this
might not be the
totally accurate movie
but it's a good time rock and roll go
get some thanks for joining everybody